-I want to talk about
that clip real quick. They --
I just introduced you. I don't
think this ever happened.
You were in a clip where
you didn't even have a line.
[ Laughter ]
-Actually, I don't know.
I get paid
for facial expressions.
-Oh, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. But, nah, that -- this
is an episode that's coming up.
It's the next new episode --
comes on Wednesday.
Mariska does this crazy
Emmy-type acting on there.
It's so --
It's a very, very heavy show,
and you shouldn't miss it.
I'm kind of small
in the episode,
because it's so much
about Mariska, this episode.
-Got ya.
-And, yeah, I'm proud, man.
19 years on this show.
-That's crazy.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You know? [ Laughs ]
[ Cheers and applause continue ]
-I heard that, at one point --
'cause 19 years,
like, patterns can develop.
-Yeah.
-Obviously, characters
become known to the audience.
And there was almost --
there was a drinking game
that then went away
because the writers
heard about it.
-There's a bunch of stupid games
that go along with "SVU."
I don't know. You know,
the fans do they things.
We love them to death,
but they come up
with all these different games,
every time
Ice says this or says that.
It's strange to me.
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
Well,
it's strange to me that --
that you would watch a show
about horrific crimes...
-And get drunk.
-...and think,
"We should drink."
Yeah. "We should..."
-Yeah.
-"We should
make a game of this."
-I mean, the --
the craziest thing for me,
being on the show 19 years --
like, if you're 20 years old,
you were 1 years old
when I started "SVU."
So you have no reference point
to anything,
as far as music
or anything I did prior to that.
So, it's very interesting
to meet people on the street,
and they go, "You're a cop."
And I'm like, "I'm as far
as you can get from a cop."
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Yeah, that is true.
I think that speaks to how life
has -- life has second acts,
because you weren't
even an actor for --
you know, I knew you, obviously,
as a...
-Yeah, music. Yeah.
-...from hip-hop and rap
and a musician.
And then,
you were in a few movies.
I knew you first
from "New Jack City."
-Yes.
-But the -- the first time
you got paid for a part,
like, you actually
got a paycheck.
-Real check?
-Real check.
-'Cause "New Jack City,"
I got like $23,000.
I was the star of the movie,
and I got what they call
SAG rate, you know?
-Yeah.
-So, everybody thought I was
rich, but I was still broke.
I blew that dough.
That -- That didn't last.
You know what I'm saying?
[ Laughter ]
After taxes, I was like,
"Man, you know,
I'm a movie star,
but I'm a broke star."
Like, "What's cracking?"
And then, I was making a movie
with Keanu Reeves
called -- called --
called "Johnny Mnemonic,"
and he had just did the one
with the --
"Speed" with Sandra Bullock.
-Yeah.
-So, I'm moving up the chain.
I'm like, "Yo, this is cracking.
I'm making things happen."
And then I get a call do a movie
called "Tank Girl."
First, they call me -- they say,
"We want you to play a stripper
in Arizona."
A stripper.
-Uh-huh.
I'm like, "Hell, yeah!"
-[ Chuckling ] Yeah.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Hell, yeah!
So, that night,
I did like a thousand crunches.
-Yeah.
I was getting my thing --
you know, getting it together,
you know.
And then,
the next day, they said --
they sent me
a picture of a kangaroo.
I'm like, "Well, what am I --
a stripper with a pouch?"
Like, "What's cracking?
Like..."
They said,
"No, you're a Ripper."
I'm like, "The movie's called
'Tank Girl'?"
I'm like -- I thought --
I mean, am I not
with Keanu Reeves?
Like what is "Tank Girl"
kangaroo moves?
Then they told me I was gonna
make over a million dollars.
I was like...
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You know, I like...
You know, I mean, you know --
I mean, you know,
call it what you will.
I have nothing
against kangaroos,
so it wasn't a sellout.
-Yeah.
And I will say you are not lying
when that was your role.
That was a million dollars
right there.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-That was --
All that prosthetics
was done by Stan Winston,
one of the greatest
who ever did it.
You know, it was a huge --
the -- the budget was huge,
and I wore those prosthetics.
Took three hours to put on
and three hours to take off
every day.
-That's insane.
-Yeah.
-I want to talk about --
your daughter
just had a birthday.
-Yeah.
-Happy birthday to Chanel.
-Chanel is incredible.
You know what I'm saying?
And my baby girl --
she's just turned 2 years old.
She had a "PAW Patrol"
birthday party yesterday.
-Yes.
[ Audience "awws" ]
-She's following
her father's footsteps
of dressing like
an animal she respects.
[ Laughter and applause ]
Here's the invitation.
What a -- What a fantastic --
"We need all the the PAWS..."
-Yeah.
-How was -- How was the party?
-I mean, it was cool.
You know, it's a kids' thing.
And, you know, I mean, I don't
remember any of my birthdays.
And I think, you know,
when you're --
you're fortunate enough
to be able to give your kids
stuff you don't have --
you know, we went out,
had a good time.
She got a bunch of toys
and stuff, so it was good.
Just, you know, you --
you start to live
through other people's
happiness, you know?
And I'm just seeing her laugh,
and she was with her brother,
who was out here.
Now, her brother, Little Ice,
who my fans know
when he was a kid --
he's now 26 years old.
-Yeah, I just met him backstage.
-Yeah.
-He's a grown man.
-So, she did hers at, like,
a little playground thing --
you know, play party --
party thing,
and he did his birthday
at the strip club.
-Well, that's right.
[ Laughter ]
-So he's like,
"Daddy, there was a girl,
and you put a dollar
in her butt, and it ripped.
You know, it couldn't --"
I was like,
"Oh, you had a good time."
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
I...
[ Laughter and applause ]
I just hope
everybody's invitations
went to the right house.
-Yeah.
-'Cause you don't...
[ Laughter ]
-Well -- Well, he's out
with his older sister, LeTesha,
who is like
the ultimate wingman.
Like, my -- my daughter
is the best person
to be out in the club with
if you out
trying to pick up girls.
Me and you married,
but she goes in.
-Yeah.
-She -- She walks over.
She lies for you -- everything.
-Oh, wow.
-Yeah, yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-That's so --
That's so -- so wonderful.
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, the apple don't fall far
from the tree, you know?